hi guys
welcome to this video on react native
if you wish to build mobile applications
and are confused
as to which tool to use then you're in
the right place
this video on react native will explain
what react native is
and guide you through it but wait before
beginning
if you haven't subscribed to our channel
already then make sure to hit the
subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update so here's what you'll be learning
in this session
first we'll understand what exactly
react native is
then we look at why react native is
being so widely used off lately
moving ahead we look at the differences
between react native applications
and platform specific applications after
understanding why react native is used
we'll understand some of the
prerequisites
for building applications using react
native
then we'll understand react native
fundamentals
like view state props and style
and lastly we'll end the session by
looking at some of the industry trends
of react native
so let's begin what exactly is react
native
now react native is a framework that
combines the best part of native
development
with react to build user interfaces
these applications that are developed
using react native are downloadable on
google play store and apple store
plus because most of the code you write
can be shared between platforms
react native offers a wide collection of
ui kits
and makes it easy to simultaneously
develop for both
android and ios devices but you must be
wondering
why is react native used so let's look
at some of the reasons why react native
is used
first up is cross platform cross
platform means that the applications can
easily be run
on microsoft windows linux and mac os
so you can build your code base once and
then run it on any platform
as opposed to software built natively
for a specific platform
next up is performance now the react
native apps are compiled into natively
written code
which enables it to not only work on
both the operating systems
but also functions the same way on both
the platforms
with no lags at all
moving ahead there's quicker development
now react native offers
excellent developer experience it
provides strong developer
and debugging tools with meaningful
error messages
so working with this tool becomes very
easy
a large developer community now there
are several github repositories on react
native and groups on facebook
stack overflow is an excellent website
with several developers interacting
about
issues on a regular basis next up is
wider audience
now since react native applications run
on both ios
and android devices there's a huge user
base
and lastly react native has a great
career scope
considering the pace at which the
framework took over the market
and its simple approach to resolving
development problems
the future of react native looks more
promising than ever
so these were some of the reasons why
react native is being widely adopted
so now let's go ahead and look at some
of the differences between react native
applications and platform-specific
applications
as discussed earlier react applications
work on multiple platforms
while in the case of platform-specific
applications
as the name suggests these applications
are built for the specific platform only
developers have a stronger web
development background
while in the case of platform-specific
apps they have a very strong platform's
language background in this case
when you consider ios developers have a
very strong hold of
swift which is a programming language
used to develop ios applications
and talking about android developers
have a very strong hold on java
when it comes to react native it has a
faster build time
and is less suitable for complex
applications
comparatively platform specific
applications have
a slower build time and are suitable for
complex applications
react native is best for small
development teams with limited resources
while in the case of platform specific
applications it is best used
by experienced developers who have
adequate experience in building mobile
apps so now that you know what exactly
is the difference between react native
and platform specific applications let's
look at some of the prerequisites
for building apps using react native
first up you should have a strong
holding programming concepts
like functions objects arrays and to
lesser extent
classes now understanding javascript and
all the javascript
libraries and frameworks is crucial and
lastly you need to be familiar with html
and css concepts
so as long as you have a strong hold of
these then react native development
becomes very easy
so now that you know what react native
is you've understood why it's being used
some of the prerequisites for react
native let's look at the basic
concepts like view state props and
styling in react native
let's begin with view now view
is the most fundamental component of
building a ui
it is a container that supports layout
with flexbox
style some touch handling and
accessibility controls
now view maps directly to the native
view
equivalent on whatever platform react
native is running on
so here you can see there's a simple
code snippet and the output for it so as
you can see there's a hello world
message
in a render method and the same is being
rendered
and the view component here is being
imported from react native
now view as mentioned earlier acts as a
container with support for flexbox
layout
and other styles so flexbox is designed
to provide
a consistent layout on different screen
sizes
moving on to state now there are two
types of data that control a component
one is props and the other one is state
now props are generally set by the
parent
and are fixed throughout the lifetime of
a component
but for data that is going to change we
make use of state
so here you can see you have made use of
the this
dot stay dot my state in my render
method you can also use
the set state method when you want to
change it
moving on let's look at props most
components can be customized when they
are created
with different parameters these created
parameters are called props
short for properties now props are
passed from one container to another as
a way of passing data between them
so here using the name as a prop
lets us customize the message in the
component
so we can reuse our component for each
of our tv shows here
so this is how we can use props in our
component
lastly talking about style react native
uses the conventional javascript
styling for components so the style
names and values are similar to how css
works
now to style we either use inline style
or style sheet
so you can see here we've provided
inline styling with
a background color a color and a font
size
and accordingly the output is displayed
moving ahead to our last
and final section let's look at the
industry trends today
talking about salaries the average
salary of a react native developer
in india is around 6 lakh indian rupees
per annum
and the salary of a react native
developer in the us is around 96
000 us dollars per annum now as you can
see react native has a higher growth
trajectory
compared to other frameworks as a result
is being readily deployed by many
companies
applications like facebook instagram
netflix
pinterest uber uber eats among others
are developed using react native
so this was a small session on what
exactly react native is
so if you have any doubts or queries let
us know in the comment section below
thank you so much for watching keep
learning and stay tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here